we are dedicating most of our broadcast
on Wednesday to a live special focusing
on mental health it's called stop the
stigma a conversation about mental
health we want to remove the shame and
blame from the discussion around mental
illness diagnosis and this morning as
part of our commitment to tackling these
issues we're talking about Swedish DJ
Tim Bergling known around the globe as
Avicii
he revolutionized electronic dance music
and collaborated with many of the
world's top artists in April 2018 Kim
Bergling died by suicide while on
vacation in Oman
he was just 28 after his death his
parents started the Tim Bergling
foundation to advocate for the
recognition of suicide as a global
health emergency and to remove the
stigma of mental illness we recently
spoke with Tim's father class Bergling
in his first u.s. broadcast interview
how do you want people to remember your
son that's a good person a good producer
he had a good heart with his mega-hit
wake me up released in 2013 Avicii
became a global superstar the song went
to number one in 22 countries but Avicii
was ambivalent about his success in a
documentary film before his death he
talked openly about his anxiety
depression and addiction everyone knows
that I've been anxious you know
everything and that I've been trying I
think it's brave of him to to open up
that way class Bergling remembers his
son as a shy boy growing up in Stockholm
when did you first see his love of music
at home he was singing the Swedish
national hymn was he not particularly
loud and they're very proud but
obviously he was super talented you must
have been proud to see that oh yeah sure
of course
Klaus and his wife unki so the first
signs of Tim's anxiety when he was a
teenager when you have a child that's
not feeling well you try everything to
to to get the situation right again
to understand what's going on so we went
to a psychiatrist yes yes and and Tim
was I think he was 14 or 15 and he sort
of calmed down Tim as Tim's career took
off class stayed involved you ran his
business yep I did I kept the books yeah
i ironed his is you know what do you say
receipts his receipts yeah
because he put everything down in spoken
did you really hire them yeah I did
actually I did as avicii Tim traveled
the world performing up to 250 shows a
year he was a very determined guy he
went all in he obviously loved it yes I
think so of course after a couple of
years love of the work can be also a
burden father and son talked often by
phone we talked a lot about deep things
did he talk to you about his anxiety oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I had experienced
myself as young if you have experienced
it yourself you know that there are ways
to get more balanced life in 2016 Avicii
quit touring and instead focused on
making music
he was much healthier and he started
exercising and things really turned into
a very very good direction less than two
years later tim died by suicide
the suicide came as a shock to all of us
and we thought that he was really on a
better way you said you had difficulty
with that word at first suicide yes
absolutely to pronounce it it is also to
admit that you're part of this destiny
so to say how are you doing now well its
ups and downs and it's it's a life
before and now it's a life after that's
the best way you can express it in June
of this year Tim's parents released the
third
avicii album with music he was working
on just before his death the proceeds
are going to the Tim Bergling foundation
what's your goal with the foundation
trying to get the stigma away from
talking about mental illness and suicide
we hope we can be a voice through Tim
because Tim had so many millions of
hands what would you say to fans of his
who might be dealing with with some of
the things that he dealt death you have
to talk about it and you have to you
shouldn't be afraid to ask for help on
December 5th in Stockholm there will be
a tribute concert Avicii tribute concert
for mental health awareness will feature
19 of the original singers on Ichi's
music including Adam Lambert Rita Ora
Aloe Blacc and there'll be a 30-piece
live band Anthony this is so frightening
here you have the father saying we were
aware that there were issues
yeah they got hope for the issues they
thought that he was doing better doing
music he was seemingly very happy what
are you supposed to do as a parent when
you think that you've done everything
and they appear to be I think that's the
way it's so hard for them yeah yeah it's
you know it's a constant vigil and you
know as a parent you you you ask
yourself over and over again what like
what else could I have done
well glad he's bringing awareness to it
we're gonna also be bringing awareness
to it you can see our live special stop
the stigma a conversation about mental
health that is this Wednesday right here
on CBS this morning